ciao a reader se benvenuti in un
nuovissimo
video sono passati ormai credo due o tre
anni dal mio ultimo video ask nonché il
primo perché vi ricordo che è stato il
primo quindi è arrivato il momento di
farle un altro con delle domande che mi
avete appunto fatto voi su instagram
partiamo subito sei una tipa spericolata
faresti mai vaggi jumping
guarda credo gli esseri la tipa meno
spericolata della storia non fare mai
bungee jumping per molti aspetti sono
molto intraprendente cose riguardano ora
il mio lavoro lo spettacolo è di busto
per altre tipo queste no assolutamente
anche per quanto riguarda tipo le
giostre quell'adrenalina che le montagne
russe cose ragazzi no proprio non è il
mio io sono un tifone come vi siete
conosciuti tuoi salvatore allora questa
è una storia molto lunga lo so avete
ragione vi ho sempre detto che un giorno
che l'avrei spirata bene la riassumo ci
ha presentato un amico che avevamo in
comune
ognuno di noi aveva delle altre storie
sono passati un po di anni sui social
c'erano aggiunge like we like la ci
siamo rincontrati qui a milano lui
viveva a roma gli a milano
frequentazione
poi ci siamo allontanati poi un taglio
era milano e da lì
tutto il resto è storia ai fratelli e
sorelle sì ho una sorella più grande
livello di 8 anni che si chiama dio mar
lo so nome strano io sono stata più
fortunata perché il mio nome è marina da
quanto sono finanziata solo finanziata
dal 2016 quindi se la matematica non è
un'opinione
6 fantastici anni ti sei mai ubriacata
così tanto da ricordare per niente
giorno dopo
allora proprio non ricordare niente
no non sono arrivate a quei livelli ma
un po di anni fa
diciamo che
mi divertivo abbastanza per quanto
riguarda serate cocktail eccetera
eccetera diciamo che qualche bella
sbronza me la sono presa e alcune se li
ricorda anche mia mamma magari faremo un
video dove mia mamma vi racconterà le
cose più shock che ho fatto nella mia
adolescenza non niente di che però
apparire cosa ti piace fare oltre ai
video allora non tutti lo sanno ma amo
tantissimo cucinare quando tempo perché
ovviamente con lavoro che faccio non ho
spesso temo restare a casa e dedicare
nella cucina ma quando tempo mi piace
tantissimo la cosa che mi rilassa e devo
dire che me la cavo abbastanza
soprattutto per quanto riguarda i primi
e i dolci sui secondi ci devo ancora
attimo lavorare mi piace tantissimo
viaggiare e poi mi piace tantissimo va
beh ovviamente recitare e poi piace
tantissimo cantare lo sapete lo sapete
benissimo e spoiler potrebbe arrivare
una nuova canzone quando ho visto per la
prima volta salvatore cosa hai pensato
di lui allora ho pensato che bono ma ho
anche pensato
se la tira ho avuto questa impressione
anche se in realtà poi
conoscendolo non è assolutamente così
preferisci mario montagne è stato
inverno allora una volta che avrei
risposto sicuramente mare estate devo
dire che col passare degli anni di sorso
diventando vecchia
inizio ad apprezzare anche l'inverno la
copertina la cioccolata calda il clima
natalizio la neve vedere la neve fuori
dalla fine su queste cose quindi anche
che guarda la montagna che stanno
iniziando a piacere di più però ecco sei
proprio devo scegliere sicuramente
ancora il mare restate mi dà quel
brivido in più come e quanto ti alleni
allora in questo periodo in questo anno
sono stata molto poco costante nel senso
che a inizio anno mi allenavo tantissimo
tutti i giorni
purtroppo con l'allenamento questo
rapporto che voglio assolutamente
cambiare cioè ovi alleno tantissimo
oppure per tipo 12 mesi non mi alleno
più
ecco sono esattamente in quei mesi in
cui non mi sto allenando e quindi mi
sento in colpa perché ovviamente a me
piace piace l'allenamento piacere
vedervi forma piace proprio fare
attività fisica che comunque fa bene
anche appunto allo stato psicofisico
devono iniziare devono iniziare poi in
vista dell'estate figura che dobbiamo
tonificare la gauche hai mai frequentato
una scuola di canto
silone o frequentate alcune ecco devo
dire che va beh un po come a scuola con
le varie materie per
trovarsi bene appunto con un insegnante
di canto ci vuole anche quel minimo di
non chimica come si dice di empatia eco
empatia
ecco io non ho mai trovato insegnanti
che con cui con i quali sono uscita
empatizzare quindi
non andavo con piacere a lezione mi
piacerebbe cercare un vocal coach e
adesso magari appunto in vista di quando
registro le varie canzoni
speriamo di trovare un valido se avete
qualche consiglio scrivete me lo sento
quali sono i tuoi idoli questa è una
bella domanda
che ha tante risposte nel senso che
ovviamente non ho solo un idolo ma ne ho
tanti sicuramente
migliori mente raffaella carrà
parentesi quando ho scoperto che è morta
sono stata malissimo tutto il giorno e
lei è un idolo per me perché appunto è
stata una delle prime a saper fare tante
cose in tv ha come dire rompere gli
schemi
c'è stato proprio un ispirazione per me
da bambino ho sempre sui programmi con
mia nonna cetra eccetera quindi un po mi
ha cresciuta per quanto riguarda la
comicità non vi nascondo che sono
cresciuta a pane e verdone e che ragioni
quindi
indicarlo aver rilevato ben arcioni mi
hanno anch'essi cresciuta credo che se
non avessi fatto indigestione di questi
film magari adesso non farei questi
video così comici così così tante
parodie così tante esagerazioni ecco
diciamo che mi hanno dato
quell'imprinting questi film per quanto
riguarda il canto un idolo immenso e
sarà sempre good news michael jackson ci
diciamo coloro che hanno
dato il via la all'epoca della musica
pop del re del pop michael jackson
la regina dell'hard è in b e del poco
news cioè
nomi che hanno fatto la storia ecco
perché i miei genitori sono in paesi
diversi perché sono divorziati mio padre
vive in spagna ea ma sta qui in italia
con me e
niente perché sono divorziati da quando
sono nata non vivono più insieme o
vivono più
italia ma il mio padre appunto è tornato
nel suo paese lo spagnolo e niente io
vado ovviamente a trovarlo in spagna è
però sto più vicino a mia madre perché
non andremo a torino e vivo a milano e
quindi siamo più vicine ha mai portato
l'apparecchio
non so perché ci ho pensato si no
portati tre credo uno mobile uno fisso e
dulcis in fundo quello col baffo non so
se avete presente quella roba atroce che
purtroppo ho dovuto mettere per un anno
quello prendeva tutte la testa e aveva
attaccato all'apparecchio questi basti
che si attaccavano qui alla capotta
viene l'ansia solo a pensarci niente
però grazie a questo dei battenti adesso
ma diciamo della piccola ho scoperto
abbastanza anche perché magari sembrava
casa dall'amichetta e cioè sembrava un
mostro però importante mi raccomando
metterli da piccoli non fate l'errore
poi di non mette ricette ovviamente se i
vostri genitori hanno la possibilità di
pagarsi un dentista e ripagare il
apparecchio approfittatene da piccoli
per poi da grande ovviamente è ancora
più fastidioso pizza sushi o hamburger e
patatine a cosa proprio non riesce a
rinunciare
ragazzi io da buona italiana
pizza la pizza non toglietemi la fa
hamburgers uscito come volete sì ogni
tanto ma posso benissimo fare a meno
credo che addirittura potrei rinunciare
per la pizza alla pasta però c'è visto
che non c'era la passa tra queste
opzioni la pasta la teniamo però proprio
per farvi capire la pizza è la cosa che
mi viaggio di più al mondo e se fosse
proverà a mangiare tutti i giorni di
base la mangio 2 3 volte a settimana non
sto scherzando eccoci arrivati alla fine
del video fatemi sapere se piaciuto se
avete altre domande scrivete però qui
sotto oppure su instagram magari una
terza parte oppure rispondono
direttamente appunto sulle stories the
ram io vi mando un bacio grande